It was a,
it was about advancement and it was also
about the claim that somehow they have
like special expertise.
This is a special technical language.
No one else can understand it.
Only only weekend,
but what's absurd about it absolutely
ludicrous is that these people,
these,
these American academics are imitating
the contorted language of French at the
translations from the French.
Okay.
When lack call is translated into,
into English,
right.
There's a contortion there.
Okay.
What he's,
what he,
what he was trying to do
in French was to break up,
okay.
The neo classical formulations
that descended from Ross scene,
there was something that was going on.
Those are sabotage of the
French language going on.
There was necessary in France,
not necessarily in English.
We have this long tradition
of poetry going back to Judah,
Shakespeare and Chaucer.
We have,
we have our own language.
We're far more vital than
that than the French.
The French constrained
their language all the time.
By my dear absurdity
in the amateur is ism.
Okay.
Of of American academics
trying to imitate,
okay.
A translation of lack hall when
like doing something in France.
That is absolutely not necessary and
indeed wrong to be doing in English,
but the other cynical abandonment,
okay.
Of the great tradition of,
of,
of uh,
of the English departments and I felt
that the true radicalism was not about
adding on other departments.
Okay.
So we have African American
studies and you know,
end to end in women's studies and so on.
The true radicalism would we have
been just to shatter the departmental
structure.
That's what I wanted.
I feel that was the authentic
revolutionary 1960 going to do.
Right.
Do I look to them to
blend all the literature,
literature studies?
Yeah.
It's all these together.
Okay.
Do have to make easier to make an
interdisciplinary kind of organization,
you know,
a little bit closer to the British
model where a person can pursue related
subjects,
overlapping subjects.
I did it,
it,
these,
this departmental models.
Okay.
Are,
were,
were to me totalitarian to begin with.
Okay.
Separating language into fiefdoms and,
and what,
what does the to create English,
WWE women's studies department.
Absolutely.
I out of the air,
just snap your fingers and
create women's studies.
The English department had
taken a century to develop.
Okay.
The way it was a huge argument.
Within,
within it.
All right.
And all of a sudden to create,
okay.
It department,
would they politicize
agenda from the start?
Hey,
by people without any training,
whatever in that field.
Right.
What should be the,
what should be the
parameters of the field,
which should be the
requirements of their field.
How about biology?
Okay.
If you're going to be discussing gender,
that should have been a
number one requirement.
Okay.
As part of any women's
studies department or program.
But no.
Okay.
It was all hands off.
It was just the administrators want it
to solve a public relations problem.
Right.
They had a situation with
very few women faculty.
Are you nationwide at a time
when the women's movement had,
had just started up,
the spotlight of attention was,
was on them.
They want,
they needed women faculty fast.
They needed the women's
subject on the agenda fast.
Right.
So they just like Poof,
let there be women's studies.
Okay.
And now we'll just hire some women.
It usually from English
departments and you know,
he hit here and there and
we'll just throw them together.
You invent it,
you say what it is.
So that's why women said he's got frozen
at a certain point of the ideology of
the early 1970s I was
already in revolt from it.
Okay.
I was a precursor in terms of my
endorsement of feminism before,
before even now it was created.
Right.
But I couldn't,
yeah.
I couldn't even have a conversation
with any of these women.
They were hysterical about
this subject of biology.
They knew nothing about hormones and I,
I mean I,
I w I probably got in
fist fights over this.
They went,
people were so convinced
that biology had nothing,
whatever to do with gender differences.
That also seems to me to be related
to the postmodern emphasis on power.
Yes.
Because there's a,
there's something terrible under round
going on there and that is an eye.
I think this is the sort of thing that
was reflected in the Soviet Union to in
the,
especially in the 20s when there was
this idea of radical idea that you could
remake human beings entirely,
right?
Because they had no essential nature.
And so if your fundamental hypothesis
is that nothing exists except power,
and you believe that,
then that also gives you the right,
in some sense to exercise your power
at the creation of the kind of humanity
that your utopian vision envisions.
Then that has no that,
and that also seems to me to justify the
postmodern insistence that everything
is only a linguistic construct.
It again goes down to the notion of power,
which Dera,
dawn's Sukkot and lockout or
some bloody obsessed with.
And so,
and it seems to me what
they're trying to do is to,
to take all the potential power for the
creation of human beings to themselves
without any bounding
conditions whatsoever,
right?
There's no history,
there's no biology,
there's and,
and everything is a fluid culture
that can be manipulated at will.
And so I mean in,
in Canada,
there a terrible arguments right
now about biological essentialism,
let's say.
And one of the things that happened,
which was something I objected
to precisely a year ago,
is that the social constructionist view
of human identity has been built now
under Canadian law.
So there's an insistence
that biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression,
and sexual proclivity very independently
with no causal relationship between any
of the levels.
And so that's in the law.
And not only is it in the law,
it's being taught everywhere.
It's being taught in the armed forces,
it's being taught in the police.
It's being taught to the elementary school
kids and the junior high school kids.
And underneath it all,
I see this terrible striving for arbitrary
power that's associated with this
crazy utopianism and,
and,
but I still don't exactly understand it.
I don't like,
I don't understand that.
What seems to be the
hatred that motivates it,
that you see bubbling up,
for example,
in identity politics and,
and in the desire to do nothing but
let's say demolish the patriarchy.